if you want to journey deep into
Beijing's economic ambitions Huawei's
european-style campus is a good place to
start the telecommunications giant is
emblematic of the country's plan to
become a global leader in a number of
key industries the government's made in
China 2025 strategy reflects the desire
to move away from low-cost manufacturing
and towards high tech as well as
communications that Chinese government
is also investing heavily in transport
energy and digitization traditionally
it's gained a lot of its know-how from
abroad over the years the huge Chinese
market has attracted many foreign firms
to the country including German car
makers keen to carve out a niche but in
recent times China has been producing
more homegrown firms in the area of
electric mobility it's already proven
itself as a trailblazer suggesting that
Western firms will have to buckle up to
stay competitive now a report by German
think-tank Marek's has cautioned against
what it calls naivety in dealings with
China
it says Western firms could lose their
competitive edge electric batteries
bring the point home 7 out of 10 of the
world's biggest makers come from China
leaving European firms scrambling to
catch up with me now this studio is Anna
Holtz MA she conducted this study at the
micarta Institute Anna welcome to the
studio that this study is pretty grim
reading for people here in in Europe but
what is Beijing's ultimate NGO world
domination or and should we be worried
about this well so the ultimate goal
clear is technological leadership on a
global scale however we're not talking
about technological leadership in every
single aspect of technology and so we
really see a difference in China's
approach with regard to let's say more
traditional high-tech areas for instance
aviation in these areas China's content
with just developing domestic abilities
that are sufficiently good so to say so
the products the components the
technology and does not need to be you
know state-of-the-art but sufficiently
good a different story needs to be told
them in the in the realm of future
technologies emerging technologies here
trying to really seize its chance to
forge ahead from the start to set the
pace and see Western industrial nations
you know try to catch up the same pace
for them for the rest of us though for
here in Europe and the rest of the world
record form your study at Germany is one
developed nation whose economic base
could be directly threatened by China's
ambitions and yet you classified Germany
as a willing partner are we selling out
to China yeah this is a really critical
point of our study we identified Germany
as a core partner as part of made in
China 2095 especially with regard to
smart manufacturing there's been a
long-standing long-lasting corporations
and the attitude of a lot of actors
involved does not really match the
changing realities in China so what does
that mean in India terms it means that
China has already developed considerable
strength in certain areas especially in
these fields and yes Germany and German
actors in the government but also in
companies also in the academic realm are
all too willing and often too naive in
their engagements with China one of your
recommendations and a quote from your
study again is initiate steps to limit
dependence on critical components from
China that of course rings of Huawei it
is Trump right on Huawei what role does
that company play in this game
well Wow is a prime example of one of
China's national champions the champions
who've gone global and now really trying
to well dominate or shape the global
market in in their respective realm I do
not think that Trump's approach of
decoupling is the solution there
especially not for Europe so we really
need to find their own solution we
should be aware of our own strengths and
we should also know Huawei is not the
only company out there so it really is
before our well it is a matter of trust
and yeah then Trust when it comes to
business
is a very special problem there another
figure that comes from from your study
that in 2018
China's spend about 300 billion u.s.
dollars on research and development
that's nearly 2.2 percent of GDP that's
more than the EU does the sheer scale
can that be matched by anyone well I
would not recommend to try and match or
you know take up China in matters of
scale so your real needs to find its own
answer in that your policy is part of it
it's an illusion to say that in German
it also Europe there's no Industrial
Policy the question is what is the right
measure where do we position ourselves
on this spectrum of different measures
of industrial policy and support for
research also basic research is
certainly critical component and there's
certainly still lots of work to be done
in Europe on a husband thank you very
much